[Music]
but I suddenly lose control there's a
fire within
[Music]
here I go again my my how can I resist
Oh Mamma Mia does it show again my my
just how much I've missed
[Music]
we just met today yes but when you know
you know when you're 44
[Music]
my mind
[Music]
you Napoleon did surrender oh yeah and I
have met my destiny in quite a similar
way the history book on the shelf always
repeating itself
I was defeated one
[Music]
promise
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I've decided to commit to being a
gremlin
25 years to me I say we move past that
you know so being a grudge holder makes
you fat
so which is concentrate on here and now
and me stepping out to becoming a good
grandmother a great grandma thank you
no he's saying wait no sky1 sanity we
agreed so I only told Sam because he's
my stepfather and also one third of my
real father
I just told build he's my best friend
and I told Harry is five number three I
told many many people married the rest
of our lives the best of our lives
[Music]
I've even I play young great developing
and I'm Jessica and okay Tanya
this prequel this is the story of the
dynamos of how they began where they
came from
you just sort of explore it deeper and
get to know them and understand why they
got to where they go to you in the
[Music]
was such a spirit of power and strength
that you see these dynamos in their
element so you're flung right into the
heart of their girls
Alexa and Deb they are absolutely
hilarious say hello in my mind are so
funny I was paying think like that
people like calm down I think we've all
gotten along so well and I think you're
really gonna see that bond and it's
gonna translate on screens
[Music]
gonna be rebellious it's going to be
quite hard hitting it's gonna be a lot
of fun boomers like going on your person
amazing summer holiday as a teenager and
my kinda the best time of your life
Hecky that's what was I have never felt
closer to mom I'm in the exact same
place that she was all those years ago
you're pregnant
yeah
tonight it's an eye for celebration come
on let's get it show the road I was told
you couldn't come I'm a spontaneous
person no I don't know no I'm not
[Music]
these are my dad's
it takes three great men to create such
a woman I never did ask you guys what
happened when you met my mother I don't
know what my future holds but the world
is wide I want to make some memories
there's an island cala Carrie people
used to think if you sailed on from
there you'd fall off the edge of the
world sounds like the place for me I'm
bill I'm Donna is literally a prince
miss man in the world
sacré this guy is always incredible I
think we should stay here together may
the rest of our lives be the best of our
lives just tell me you didn't invite
your grandmother Wicked Witch of the
West
[Music]
I've decided to commit to being a
grandmother grandma you weren't invited
that's the best kind of party little
girl
my soulmate may actually become the line
must be wine all three of us are
grandfathers that's that
[Music]
look what you've done with the place she
wanted to make the mum proud if she
hasn't done that all her life we can't
tell anybody about the baby yet
I just told bill yeah and I told Harry I
told many many people got about to
become a grandmother great-grandmother
I'm living that out of the bio there's
the most famous general in history
dancing queen ace walk normally I was
about I dared to say this is a much
bigger production than the original we
have helicopters we have boats we have
dancing on boats we have dancing
downhill site you have stunt guys
watching this unfold is fantastic
dancing queen is the arrival of the
flotilla of boats and then we all go
down the hill and it's reminiscent of
the first movie everyone is in dancing
greeting it's the reunion of all the
actors from the first film once you hear
the music dancing clean you just gonna
let it rip once you hear it you still
can't help but just be ecstatic it's
like the Hallelujah Chorus and you're
just surrounded by orchestration all has
set it so beautifully it fits
dancing queen quite well because dancing
queen has become like a hymn
[Music]
missile for just sweet Harry very he is
one of the greatest pop singers in
history she came out and this spotlight
was on her and she absolutely came to
life she's made something very a
spine-tingling just a few minutes cher
is gonna be up on that balcony
singing Fernando can you believe that
every time you offer someone a part you
have to have the next person in mind but
in this case there was certainly one
there was this share I come in a
helicopter and then I land and I come
walking up with a cane and I'm I'm
different
let's get the party started they're
playing my mother of course when I used
to hear Abba is so fabulous I mean the
lyrics are just totally grab me
it's things I felt a million times so it
was easy to sing it was so much fun to
see her she was defined the anticipation
made the air crackle it's absolutely
fabulous sheer talent of the lady acting
C and being shared so hear her sing
Fernando she was perfect for that song
all of a sudden you have chair another
together
it's exciting anything it was just
amazing to Kai I
song to see I'm so glad you're here
I'm pregnant but I don't know how to do
this by myself
your mother is the bravest person we
ever made my baby
let me tell you how she did it all on
her own
[Music]
life is short the world is wide
I want to make some memories
this dress might look very pretty on you
you don't know me at all do you
[Music]
I think we should stay here together I
wish I could stay here too turns out
he's engaged I hate it when they do that
I was cheated by you and I think you
know when look at me now
well I ever learned I don't know how but
I suddenly lose control there's a fire
within my soul never felt closer to my
mom she wasn't scared because she had me
we can't tell anybody else about the
baby okay
I just told bill and I told Harry I told
many many people let's get the party
started grandma you weren't invited
that's the best kind of party little
girl I was cheated by you and I think
you know and had no idea Lily James had
these singing chops I don't know how but
I suddenly lose control some people sing
from the bottom of their feet right up
[Music]
he shakes the rafters she's amazing the
world is wide I want to make some
memories
when I found out I would be part of the
sequel phenom Mia I was terrified and
very excited dawn as a character so
beloved and Meryl Streep is the best
actress of all time and Lily has great
energy and her spirit is what young
Donna was I am definitely staying here
forever
she's just perfect
[Applause]
Michelle Clapton is the costume designer
and she just got the characters what's
been great about this film is that
they've all grasped the idea that you
can have fun they've been up for really
trying anything but you meet us by our
Beauty just iconic aren't they the stars
became a sort of it almost like a logos
throughout the film
I just looked at all the outfits that
Michelle had picked out and I just was
like yes and she totally got an
understood Donna the dungarees have to
feature the iconic those dungarees it
ended up being a look that defined her
Lily was really excited about it here
into this little Merrill shuffle they
put them on and I went oh yeah I feel
like Donna costumes make it I mean once
we put on the costumes I really think
it's your character take a look at this
costume this costume is pretty much worn
by the younger versions in the movie
it's meant to be a little kind of funky
and thrown together the goal the jacket
well not to love they have to be able to
move so that's very key to these
clusters which is why they're stretched
the mama mia costume is so fun it's so
girly it's so flirty when the girls put
on the costumes they just became the
dynamos
[Music]
you